hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
the use of 3d models in hepatic biology
i'm christie jewel of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored
by thermo fisher scientific for more
information on our sponsor please visit
thermofisher.com now let's get started
i would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send also please notice you
can share this webinar on your personal
social media
just click on the social sharing tab to
let your friends and colleagues know
about today's live event if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of your presentation window
or use that ask a question box to let us
know you're experiencing a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'd now like to introduce today's
presenters dr david cunninger director
and group leader thermo fisher
scientific
julia tritipo r d scientist cell biology
at thermo fisher scientific
and also joining us today is michael
millett scientist one cell biology
at thermo fisher scientific for a
complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
david you may now begin your
presentation
yes uh thank you for that introduction
kristy
um hello my name is david cunninger
i'm a director of r d at thermal fischer
scientific and it's
my pleasure along with two of my
colleagues to present
uh this webinar on in vitro 3d storage
culture models
using human primary hepatocytes hepa rg
cells
and primary animal hepatocytes
okay so i thought i'd start with some
broad terms and definitions
as as we sort of get more specific into
the hepatic models
so um you know broadly what is uh what
is a 3d model
um it can mean a number of different
things this uh
illustration is just meant to kind of
convey
the broadness uh in which uh you know
folks
are often will uh term or consider
various uh in vitro models as 3d
and so just going from left to right
we've got traditional monolayer
um and then moving more towards right
we have you know more more classic uh
culture models that can be used with a
transwell inserts these
have been around for decades and and
then
uh getting more into what what i think
we
more properly or more more
timely definitions of 3d models and
that's the spheroids and organoids
and then moving into more complex
systems such as organs on enchantment
behind bioprinting
um you know really the key
the key rationale for for building these
more complex systems
is to drive more physiologically
relevant responses
out of out of the different cell models
and i think this will be
illustrated uh with the hepatic models
that we'll be discussing in detail
so the next slide gets into um
into the a bit more with the models and
this is really parsing
definitions between steroids and
organoids and and
i think um i tend to think of these as
somewhat loosely defined um
sort of working definitions are shown
here so with the spheroid
um you know is a 3d aggregate composed
of you know one or more cell types
that uh grow and proliferate
although not all models that necessarily
will proliferate um coming back to this
uh but but also um often uh
exhibit enhanced physiological responses
and you know may or may not may or may
not go more complex processes of
self-organization
and differentiation
[Music]
in contrast organoids are typically
derived from
proliferating populations that are
capable of self-organizing
and these are often taken from
are initiated from either pluripotent
stem cells or tissue derived progenitors
that are capable of
both proliferation and then more more
complex
formation of more complex structures and
different cell types um and
also tends to mimic the in vivo
architecture
of the tissues more often uh below is
just a number of uh
cell sources that can be uh derived
to initiate both serotonin or organoid
cultures
and with that i will
keep rolling
okay so getting into our primary hepatic
human steroids specifically
um so so why uh again why would
researchers
uh scientists be interested in using 3d
hepatic cultures
um you know you can read through the
slides here
the the table here the the bottom line i
think there's really
a couple key features uh one is
uh the physiological responsiveness
of hepatocytes in 3d is much more robust
than 2d
the longevity most of you
listening may may know this or may not
but
typically at least human primary
hepatocytes when
plated uh ex vivo um don't last very
long you can um
you know a week uh if they played at all
and uh maintaining the cultures at you
know high viability
and high high level of confluence
and activity uh for a week is a is a
challenge
uh so so this provides a fairly narrow
window and fairly challenging conditions
to be able to do this consistently
uh in contrast the 3d spheroids
of these hepatocytes so these are these
would be non-proliferative
human primary hepatocytes that are
um cultured in a way that promotes their
self-aggregation
so so in this case with the primary
human haps and the
the animal models that julia will speak
to later these are non-proliferative
cell types so we're using culture
conditions that promote
the self-aggregation of these uh cells
into spheroid structures
so not non-proliferative um
for the primary heps but but once they
form these spheroids
they maintain viability and
functionality for weeks
uh and on a per cell basis are much more
active so you get much longer term
cultures
and and much higher activity um in some
ways the complexity
um once you one has a lot of cells that
that
have been screened or you know they're
capable of forming steroids
it's actually not that difficult to
consistently create spheroids in these
multi
in in the the sphere and 96 well plates
is that the format that we've been
using uh fairly extensively
it's actually fairly straightforward to
do unlike plating monolayer cultures of
primary human hepatocytes which which
can be
uh challenging to do consistently
um yeah some of the other
again from a biological standpoint
um the longer culture windows enable
at the study of low turnover compounds
the ability to
recapitulate more complex
pathophysiological
accomplish disease type processes and
co-cultures becomes
[Music]
attractive
and uh one a paper i will reference a
little bit later
also suggests that the or indicates the
productivity
uh with with certainly with respect to
hepatotoxicity
uh is vastly improved in the 3d cultures
versus a traditional 2d
uh from the same source so a number of
really a key benefits in using
3d culture in this type of 3d culture
system
okay so i'm going to jump right into the
workflow
with uh our primary human hepatocyte
spheroid
system or kit this is a actually a a kit
we put together
launched last year about nine
ten months ago that consists of
cryopreserved human hepatocytes
that have been pre-qualified screened
for their ability to
uh robustly form steroids uh
the the the thaw plating and maintenance
media
uh required as long as in addition the
uh knuckle on sphere 96 wall plates so
uh to enable the the sphere and
formation uh
and maintenance um the workflow showed
at the top
it's again pretty pretty straightforward
you just stall count and plate
um as the the cartoon indicates the
cells initially
uh you know our individual uh
singular uh singularized and then they
uh in in the
ultra low inherent round bottom uh
knuckling sphero plates the cells will
self-aggregate
and form these steroids over time we
typically will play
and leave them unperturbed until day
five where we do a media change
and inspect the cells for the quality
morphologically the quality is here in
formation
and at that point is when we would we
typically start to do
uh experiments with with these cells and
this is in contrast to
uh the depletable version of these cells
by day five they're really exiting their
usable window
for the most part uh the picture below
uh the photo micrographs just show you
know what this looks like
when you're appearing under the
microscope and again i think just the
box on the right well you see a kind of
a blow up
on the upper right of what these uh
steroids look like
at a higher mag and then just the
components of
the kit shown in the box
oh yes so uh we've
as we've been working more and more with
these 3d models uh the hepatic 3d models
and
and others uh frankly we've been we've
been learning a lot
um about you know kind of what works uh
what doesn't work and what
are things that we have to adapt along
the way so
we've tried to sprinkle in a few uh
helpful
tips um that you know that that we've
learned to either help with the workflow
or perhaps
give you more reliable results uh with
different
types of downstream assays and in this
case our tip is uh if you're using the
multi-well plates
um consistently doing media changes and
or washes can be prop
you know challenging uh with a single
spheroid in there so
uh we really like the well uh an
automated microplate washer
the well washer well wash versus one we
use routinely
really facilitates um the ease of use
the speed
and i think probably helps with
consistency of the overall cultures
using using
a system like this
okay this diagram there are other
commercial uh options for
um pre-qualified blocks of uh human
preserved human uh hepatocytes
and this this uh slide is just meant to
indicate that this
our system on the left is when we spent
a lot of time
uh in both this the cell optimization
and workflow optimization
and just pulling the components together
to really simplify it
and as i mentioned on the earlier slide
we basically thaw count and seed and
then leave the
the plates alone for the for the human
epada sites until day five until the the
first media change
excuse me other commercially available
available systems
require substantially more manipulation
of the cells pulling them in and out of
the incubator
multiple times to to do this so just you
know
increase risk and and more work but it's
a comparison of the workflows
okay so um this slide is just going to
walk through some of the
basic parameters that we've
sort of did in our routine optimization
across multiple uh multiple losses we
were
trying to get the uh the product and the
protocol dialed in
um essentially uh what this slide
so you have a a collection of uh photo
micrographs on the left um that go
so you can look at the the numbers at
the bottom 750 to
7 500. that's initial
that's cells that were seated in a
single well of the 96 well
uh nuncalon sphero plate and so we're
increasing cell numbers from from left
to right
these images are taken on day five
following the the workflow i showed
earlier and
what we see is a fairly con so these are
just replicas that you see
in the column form and as we we go
across the rows
increasing size as we increase initial
seating density
we can quantitate that uh by analyzing
the images
and uh calculate the volume uh so we're
able to as you can see
on the left and i also see the
connotation on the right we're able to
increase the size of the spheroids by by
by starting with with more cells
uh in the initial seating uh within this
range
so and as one would hope i guess or
expect to see that that spirit volume
volume is proportional to the number of
cells per well so so we feel like for
the most part with these th
the vast majority of the cells that are
seeded uh viable cells that are seeded
up
are are included in the formation of
these
uh these spheroids this data is a
consistent hematite
okay so uh kind of a a look
inside of these spheroids so what we've
got two types of staining here these are
cells that when fixed and stained
the top again if you look at the numbers
at the lower right of each of the images
represent the the the starting cell
number at the time of spheroid cd
um so so what we see is again sort of an
increase in size as we're going from the
lower to higher number of cells
but also if we look at the top panel
this is a hematoxylin
substanding h and e staining of sections
of cryo sections of the spheroids
so we see a fairly uniform distribution
of cells so these are
solid masses of cells that are that are
fairly uniformly distributed
um these are just hepatocytes so we
again we just did this is really
monoculture um the lower uh
row shows uh total stating
um of sections um as indicated and here
um so so we're looking for uh you know
tunnel as an indicator of
uh precursor of cell death um
and what we're really looking for was
can we identify
uh hypoxic or necrotic
zones in these spheres of any size so
really looking for a concentration of
signal
uh within the core uh the center of
these and
you know certainly within the the size
range and the culture conditions and
duration that that we've
been typically doing we we don't we have
yet to have consistently identify sort
of
necrotic uh cores in any of these uh
any of the uh uh steroids
okay so uh let's see how do they work uh
so now we're looking
at uh gene expression uh
in this case we're we're comparing
relative to 2d
uh cultures so the same same loss of
same same cells
either cultured in 2d at day 5
or in 3d at the indicated times here and
we're looking out
one to four one to four weeks out
we've got three different lots so if you
maybe it's a little bit hard to read but
the hu
dot dot those are all different uh three
different lots
of cells that we're looking at in
parallel this is uh
rtpcr qpcr analysis of
a different uh sips uh or
transporter a specific transporter or an
albumin so just starting from left to
right
at the top we're looking at c3a induct
uh expression
mrna levels uh relative to
the blue the blue bar which you probably
can't see because the levels are so low
at day five
relative to um those are all set at one
also because we're
normalizing but so we see enhanced set
three
a four expression in all the donors
although although we do know
there's donor dental variability uh
similarly sip 2d6 expression
is substantially elevated in uh all
three
of the steroid lots relative to the same
cells plated in 2d
the mdr-1 transporter
similarly high levels uh
in all of the steroid cultures
relative to 2d and uh same with albumin
in this case so but again
consistent with what we would expect to
see is enhanced
expression of these key transporters
that drive
that that are at the the basis of some
of the fundamental physiological
uh actions that are that are relevant
for for many
uh folks with these types of cells
okay so a little more functional
characterization in this case we're
looking at uh at well we're looking at
the formation of bile ducts
um via cfda staining
on the on the
on the left upper left panels so
um what you can see is the top so the
we're showing uh the top row is primary
human
uh hepatic spheroids uh the lower
row is a hepatic cell line to have g2
which is does not form bile ducts of
bioparticuli
so we have a that's our negative control
for cfda staining
a dappy just to show steroids are there
and then you can see the the co-standing
in the merged image so this is something
we fairly consistently see
with the spheroids if we're looking at
uh
activity the upper uh the
figure in the upper right we're looking
at activity of the
specific activity for the set 3a4
transporter
in the 3d cultures substantially higher
i would note and i think this is a
somewhat important point
that we're looking at a per cell or per
per
sort of a or per a fixed number of cells
at this point
so the the uh
the spheroids while they have a
relatively small number of cells
are very active um so
again the activity is very high
there may be certain applications where
additional biomass is going to be
required you may need
more cells than might typically be found
in a single spheroid
um so this can be addressed by pooling
this is something that we do and i'll
come back to this a little bit later but
um what
this is a common theme that we see with
the spheroid cultures
across all the models that we'll be
discussing is higher
metabolic activity relative to the cells
cultured in
the same cells cultured in tb uh and
just below that
uh we see uh improved with uh secretion
in the 3d cultures relative to the 2d
and again this is normalized on a
personal basis
okay and so
we're looking um
and increased metabolism so in this case
we're looking we're comparing
metabolism of six compounds
um across two lots of hepatocytes
that are cultured in either 2d or 3d
and what we you can see
something a little bit hard to see the
compounds
the they're at the top of each graph
what we find across the board i
should say across where with five of the
six compounds that we looked at
were increased metabolic activity
um uh with the 3d cultures
relative to their 2d counterparts
so this was uh this was consistent
um across the board except for the
hydroxy
uh beautiful
and i guess you know we're not this was
a reproducible result we're not entirely
sure
why the two want one donor of 2d scored
so high here
but um but otherwise we see we see
consistently higher metabolic activities
with the uh with the the lots
in steroid culture versus 2d
and i just wanted to highlight this all
right this is actually work from
a paper from a couple of years ago from
will
will proctor and allison foster and what
they were doing
was trying to systematically
look at whether the what they call
hepatic micro tissues these are actually
hepatic spheroids or again i think
our definitions of steroids are 3d
structures um
it's probably a little should probably
be generous and how we're
how we're using it but in this case
they're they're calling their hepatic
steroids
liver micro tissues they they were
looking at
the productivity of these structures
sorry these cultures to identify
known uh hepatic toxicants
that are known to induce uh you know a
drug-induced liver uh
injury dilly and so essentially they
took 110 compounds
and screened these of known uh
toxicological profiles and said how well
do the 3d cultures predict versus versus
2d
and it was it was pretty impressive
actually the
the the micro tissues the spheroids
showed increased sensitivity
uh increased predictivity and the
authors also suggested
that um that these models might be
useful
in identifying biomarkers related to
for biomarker mining related to hepatic
injury
so again a fairly
uh substantive work uh
indicating that the sensitivity and
specificity of
these 3d cultures relative to the same
cells in 2d
okay so with that i'll just uh wrap up
the conclusions uh here
of this section yeah so and we have uh
our git code primary human hepatocyte
kit
the skew is there um it's uh
really everything you need to get
started in 3d
uh human hepatic culture
comes with the knuckle on sphere plates
plating media and supplements and
uh in the 96 well place so
as well as uh we have fairly extensive
guidance uh
application notes some of which i think
julia will touch on
at the end web-based resources to to
aid in getting up and running with that
um yeah i think uh we'll demonstrate at
least in part that the the the
hepatic spheroid cultures the human uh
paddock sprout cultures are
capable of functionally viable at least
four weeks
substantially further than their 2d
counterparts
um yeah the
lower much lower numbers of cells are
required for equivalent activities
uh so again this may uh enable these
fairly
precious and relatively expensive cells
to be used
more more effectively and hopefully to
drive better results yeah and again we
see
uh better activity uh higher gene
expression levels uh
uh in the 3d cultures as compared to two
too deep okay with that i am going to
hand you off to my colleague michael
who's going to go over
her hepa rg uh steroid work
all right thank you david so as you said
i'm going to talk today
a little bit about some of the hep rg 3d
hepatic steroid work i've been doing
so for those of you who aren't familiar
hep rg is a
terminally differentiated hepatic cell
lime and it's derived from a human
hepatic progenitor cell line
hep rg is comprised of two different
cell types
fifty percent of patasite like cells and
fifty percent chlangiocyte
or biliary like cells and the top left
we have a liver cross section
and um those cells that make up the bile
duct are the clangiocytes and then the
surrounding apatocites are the two cell
types that compose heparin
two things that are one thing that
really separates hepar g cells from
other hepatic cell lines is that they
retain most of the characteristics
of primary primary human hepatocytes so
most of the
enzymes and pathways that people use
primary parasites for
are retained in hepar g cells two
advantages of hep rg
over primary human to pass sites are
they are much more cost effective and
cheaper for the customer
and they lack the donor or lots of lot
variability that plagues primary
satisfied work
so in the bottom left this is just a 10x
photo of a 2d frg monolayer you can see
two distinct cell morphologies in there
one of them being the
binuciated cell that is characteristic
of primary parasites
um so when i started this work we were
getting a lot of
customer inquiries as to if these cells
we used in 3d and we were seeing a lot
of recent literature about these cells
we used in 3d
but um i stood out only having an
established 2d workflow which is very
simple you just saw the cells
and plate them onto a collagen one
coated plate and then days
6 through 10 you can acid them for
various purposes
so i first set out to see if it was even
possible to form pep rg steroids
um in the top left you can see the
workflow
all you do is you follow the cells and
see the thousand of them per well of a
nunclone sphere super low attachment
u-bottom 96 volt plate
and by day two the steroids have mostly
formed
but uh by day three they're fully formed
with a really nice
outer outline that you can see here and
uh we'll actually get into later that's
actually when they're the most
functional
um in the right hand graph you can see
it's a little bit of a teaser's data i'm
about to get into but just overall um
cells are much more active in a 3d
format compared to a 2d format
this graph goes over a cyto cytochrome
p450 enzyme activity
c3a4 specifically and you can see
in a 3d spheroid format in a nunc sphere
plate um
it is the sip 304 activity is
significantly higher than even
2d induced monolayers when you induce
the cytochrome p450 enzo activity
this left bar is just the basal 3d
activity
so moving on i characterized the 3d
protocol
based on a 10-day time course of enzyme
activity in the cells this was also how
the 2d protocol was established
this left graph you can see it's
comparing the
basal sip 3a4 activity over a 10 day
time course
of 3d spheroids versus 2d monolayers
the two main takeaways are that are at
all time points
your activity is significantly higher in
3d compared to 2d
and the second main takeaway would be
that actually on day three
cells reach peak enzyme activity in a 3d
format
compared to a 2d monolayer we have to
wait through days 6 through 10
to get peak enzyme activity and so you
can assay yourselves actually much
quicker
in a 3d format compared to a 2d format
moving over to these right three graphs
um i just wanted to show that the trend
of significantly increased
uh cytochrome p45 p450 enzyme activity
held across different sip enzymes
so this left most one is tip 182
and then to the right of that is tip 2c9
and then here's pulled from the graph on
the left side 3a4
so it holds true across all those
cytochrome p450 enzymes that
we have looked at so far that there is
significantly
higher activity in 3d versus 2d that's
quarters the magnitude is higher
moving on this is just some quick um
histology stating we did
the left graph for chart is of an h e
staining of day 14 heparig spheroids
a lot of the literature states depending
on what format you grow these cells in
uh the two cell types the clanger sites
and the past sites will form one will
form a shell and the other will form the
inner ball of cells
and this little tiny cutout on the
bottom right you can see that
it does look like one cell type does
indeed form the outer shell
and one and the other cell types are in
the center
um one step we're currently doing is
just the antibody stain so we can verify
which cell type is which
over to the right we have a periodic
acid shift staining
um so the top two photos are of the day
three heparin
spirit and the bottom two photos are day
fourteen heparin spheroid the left side
is
not digested and the right side has a
glycogen digest
so the main takeaway from this would be
that it seems the cells
seem to store more glycogen over time
so uh the functionality seems to
increase
for some applications over time the
longer you let these heparin
spirits grow
okay so i want to make sure that there
was a way to scale up these heparin
steroids this left
photo is of day three hep rg orbital
shaker steroids and these were created
by seating
three million cells per well of a number
one sierra
six well flat bottom plate and three
mils per of media per well
you set them on an orbital shaker set to
85 rpms
and on day three you have hundreds if
not thousands of steroids per well
these write two graphs are just some
quick size analysis we did with these
orbital shaker spheroids
unlike the sphere plates they don't
really have a confined space to grow in
so i was expecting them to be much less
consistent in size but as you can see
from our graph
even in this oral shaker format they're
surprisingly consistent so i was really
happy with that
okay so just to sum up some of the
conclusions for heparin
3d work is that uh hephrd cells can
easily form viable 3d steroids
using nung sphere super low attachment
96 volu bottom plates
or on a nung sphere a super low
attachment flat bottom
six bowl plate placed on an orbital
shaker
hep rg spheroids have basal cytochrome
p450
c3a4 182 2c9 or some ones we looked at
that's order of magnitudes higher than
2d monolayer culture
and that is both induced and uninduced
in 2d the 3d steroids have
heat phase activity on day three as
opposed to day six through ten so you
can actually assay yourselves much
quicker
when using a 3d format
the heparng steroids also store glycogen
suggesting that they're functional
and we can see a bit of spatial
organization
when looking at these cells in 3d where
it seems one cell type
goes towards the outer edges and the
others goes towards the inner ball of
the cells
so those are all the conclusions i have
for this section with that i'll pass it
off to
julia tritipo she is a r d scientist
with us
in frederick maryland as well
okay thank you michael for that
introduction as michael alluded to
i'll be discussing our preliminary work
around our animal hepatic steroids today
so on this slide i'm just showing our
simple workflow
to form animal hepatic steroids so very
similar to
forming human hepatic steroids on the
first day
you thaw count and seed and then
for the most part uh the the clusters
are left undisturbed for five days
at that time there's a media exchange
and then during week one you can do your
assays
with the exception that with dog hepatic
spheroid formation
this does require on the initial day day
zero in this cartoon
a longer and harder centrifugation speed
and then
subsequent centrifugations on days one
and two
and that's only for the dog hepatic
spheroids for the rodent
it's just as human where you thaw count
seed and then undisturbed for five days
and then you do the media change
the photo micrographs i've shown here
are just showing
for all the different species different
cell numbers seeded per well
starting with 375 on the left and
going to 3 000 cells per well
looking at the formation and
functionality of dog hepatic spheroids
so in the top left panel again
looking at optimizing variable cell
numbers
that we're seeing here so starting on
the left 375 cells
up to 3 000 cells and you can see
there's consistency of steroid formation
among these different
seeding densities that we tried on the
top right panel looking
at uh viability as indicated by atp
synthesis
of these dog hepatic steroids you can
see that they are viable
for four weeks um which is a huge
improvement over the
same cells in 2d culture
which survive typically uh in five days
um and then looking at the bottom
left-hand panel this is looking at gene
expression in the 3d dog hepatic
steroids
and uh the first the first bar on any of
the genes we looked at so we looked at
three here we looked at albumin sip one
a one and sip two b6
and the first bar is showing um the 2d
uh gene expression so the same cells
plated in 2d
and so these graphs are looking at gene
expression as compared to
those same cells plated in 2d and you
can see for two of the genes albumin and
sip 2b6 we see increased gene expression
relative
to 2d cultures and then interestingly
for sip 1a1
while there are transcripts present they
are actually lower than
the 2d culture and this was an
interesting finding
because if you look at the bottom right
hand panel the sip 1a1 activity we're
looking at in these dog hepatic spheric
clusters
it's actually higher than what we see in
the 2d culture
so we can't exactly explain why the
transcript levels are lower yet the
activity is higher but it is
what we've what we've observed so far
with these dog hepatic steroids
moving on to formation of the rodent
hepatic steroids so on the left hand
side i have
photomicrographs of the rat and mouse
hepatic steroids
again we're optimizing this cell number
per well here
starting at 375 cells and titrating that
up to 3000 cells per well
and something i will mention with the
rodent hepatic steroids is that
um we've observed consistently
that we find irregular spheroid shapes
if you feed higher than 3000 cells per
well
and you can start to see some of these
irregular shapes in the rats
hepatic zero is even at 3 000 cells per
well
and then on the right panel looking at
viability as indicated by atp synthesis
you can see that
while the rodent hepatic steroids
are viable out the four weeks vitality
is decreasing
throughout those four weeks
this is looking at gene expression in
the rodent hepatic
spheroids for rat on the left hand side
we looked at albumin and sip
2d4 gene expression and much like dog
that i talked about a few slides earlier
these these are gene expression levels
as compared to the same cells plated in
2d
so for rat we see increased gene
expression for albumin and tip 2d4
and then for mouse on the red head side
we looked at albumin
gene expression which we see is higher
than 2d
and this peaks at week two and then
declines after that
some of the variability that we see in
this gene expression data could be due
to a low sample size so this is a single
lot that we're looking at here
so we have more work to do in this area
testing more
more lots for gene expression
this is looking at elevated albumin
production in the rodent hepatic
steroids so
um rat is on the left hand side and
mouse is on the right hand side and what
we're looking at here
is albumin secretion as compared to the
same cells plated in 2d
day 5 for day 5 2d
for the rats hepatocytes and then for 2d
day 3 for the mouse in any case we see
increased albumin secretion for
the 3d models here
so just to uh have some brief
conclusions for this section uh for
primary dog mouths and rat
patients we've we've shown we can easily
assemble these into 3d cultures
uh within five days using the nyson
sphero low attachment
u-bottom 96-well plates um all of the
animal
pad plate lots that we've tested thus
far have shown um they're capable of
forming steroids for dog
we've tested two unique lots for mouth
four lots
and for rat three lots
as i mentioned in an earlier slide the
dog a hepatic spheroid formation does
require
a harder and longer centrifugation speed
on the day of seeding
and then also additional centrifugations
on days one and two
for optimal results of forming steroids
and i think this is an important point
to think about
as it might these additional steps might
be useful in other
lots that are difficult to form steroids
then data we're not showing what we've
found is that there's multiple assays
or workflows that have been designed for
2d
that we've found require modification to
be used for 3d applications so this is
definitely something to keep in mind
across all species
as you're doing more and more work in
the 3d area
we do have a number of resources
available
on our website for different hepatic
steroid model
we have user guides for some of the
products we talked about today
different scientific posters and a
variety of application notes and again
all these can be found on our web page
so with that uh we'll thank you for your
time and we'll be happy to take any
questions
thank you julia and thank you michael
and david for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of our webinar
now to our audience if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
okay we've got some great questions
coming in let's get started
our first question what types of
experimental factors are important to
consider
when setting up studies with 3d hepatic
steroids
okay thanks christy i think maybe i can
start with this one
a couple key things to keep in mind
are really the types of questions that
that you're trying to answer
uh with the 3d models what what we found
and
i think highlighted throughout the the
webinar
was the increased activity uh that we
find
but with with lower numbers of cells and
so
you know i i think uh sensitivity of the
assays or endpoints becomes very
important here that you you have the
instrumentation or assays that are
sensitive sensitive enough to measure
from from the endpoint of interest from
a single spheroid or from multiples
depending on
kind of the required amount of biomass
and that that may take a little bit of
dialing in
and and related to that and as julia
mentioned
in her wrap up many of the
acid assays or tissue
sample preparation steps um
that are used or that are sort of
commonly used that we look at in
comparing
2d to 3d don't work very well with the
3d
micro tissues if you will that the
tissues
don't always solubilize dissociate
etc as well as just traditional
monolayer cells and so
um you know we we tend to take the
approach of treating them more
tissue like in how we and the types of
either mechanical
enzymatic or chemical dissociation uh
that that are required so those are at
least a couple things
thank you david have you looked at
primary human hepatocytes from diseased
for example individuals with nash tissue
for ability to form and function
in 3d and do you offer these
okay maybe i'll i'll answer that one too
um
we have looked um
so i'll start with the second question
we do not currently
offer uh we don't we don't have any uh
commercially
uh commercial products or available
career preserved cells from disease
models
uh sorry from individuals with different
types of
hepatic diseases or pathophysiological
conditions
what we found excuse me
in practices it's very difficult for us
to consistently isolate high quality
cells from diseased tissue and and the
heterogeneity of
the tissue that comes in is is pretty
dramatic
so that's just been a real challenge for
us thus far we're
we're working on it but we don't
currently uh have a
ready-to-go solution
thank you now our next question you
showed much higher basal activity of
sip 3a4 in the hepa rg spheroid cultures
compared to monolayer can these cells be
induced any further
this is michael i guess i'll go ahead
and answer that one um that's a great
question
i have not attempted it would be the
real answer so i'm not sure
um do you need to induce them no there
are any
orders of magnitude higher than any
induced
level of cytochrome p450 enzyme activity
you'll get in 2d monolayers
and you don't have to worry about buying
the drugs or any regulatory concerns
around the drugs
but um that's a really interesting
question and it's on my to-do list
for sure so hopefully i'll answer that
really soon
thank you michael now we're almost out
of time and we'll have to wrap with this
final question but i do want to let our
audience know that any questions we were
not able to answer today and those that
come in during the on-demand period
they will be answered via the contact
information you provided
at the time of registration okay our
final question of the day
now you mentioned that all of the lots
of various species tested form series
are these platable suspension quality or
both
yeah i can take that question it's a
really great question so
uh so far for the formation of animal
hepatic steroids we've only
tested uh those lots that are platable
in 2d culture we've yet to test any that
are suspension grade
2d hepatoplate thank you julia
now before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
i'd also like to thank dr david
cunninger michael millett and julia
tritipo for their time today
and their important research and we'd
like to thank labrods and our sponsor
thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labberts will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and we hope to see
you again soon
have a great day